what is
feminism um I think the the most common
definition is the social political and
economic equality between the Sexes so
according to that definition I would
definitely identify as a feminist okay
yeah in general I agree with that
definition I believe that we should not
be discriminated unfairly on the basis
of sex if I had to add any addition to
feminism I would agree with all that and
then I would also add on just kind of
adding more cultural currency to just
female spaces women's interests and just
proclivities in
general that
last if that's what it were but I don't
I actually think feminism does the
opposite of that in practice and frankly
going all the way back to the beginning
of feminism in the 18th century probably
my definition of feminism would be
Gloria steam's definition she was the
very famous feminist of the second wave
which is that a woman needs a man like a
fish needs a bicycle feminism is the
idea that men and women are not
complimentary they're not different and
helpful to one another but they're
identical and IND discernable that there
you know there are some superficial
differences you ladies might be a little
prettier perhaps than I am but all in
all we're basically exactly the same and
I I don't think that's true I think it's
a false view of human nature and I think
it's harmful to everybody and especially
harmful to women right I've worked with
GL steam's company wom women's Media
Center for like four years back my
condolences and obviously that's like a
more crass interpretation of I think
what she meant by that which I think is
more so she's more so um characterizing
the fact that women in general when
they're taught how to self-actualize
it's typically tied to contingency on a
man and getting married and starting a
family versus men when they're told um
the ways to self-actualize it doesn't
necessarily require a woman so obviously
her saying a woman needs a man the way a
fish needs a bicycle sounds crass and
like she's being a bit bit mandress and
obviously some radical interpretations
may take it that way but I think what
she's trying to say is that women you
can like Define yourself in your career
and your potential outside of Simply
marriage and children what do you mean
by the phrase
self-actualize um just like live up to
your potential you know use your
rational faculties you know use the
design of your potential in your brain I
I agree that I want to live up to my
Highest Potential I want women to live
up to their Highest Potential I want
Total human flourishing but I think
you've given away the game on the
radical and liberal Foundation of
feminism which is the notion that it
comes purely from the self it's a matter
of self- Liberation that that I can do
totally
self-sufficiently as if I were an island
unto myself but no man is an island unto
himself and so I didn't make myself I uh
didn't create the family that I was born
into I didn't create the community that
I was born into the country that I was
born into I take the opposite view of
the liberal view the Liberals say that
man is fundamentally an individual the
conservatives would say no man is a
social creature you know man is a
political animal and so the irony I
think of someone like a glorious dyum
saying that we we or insinuating that we
just want women to live up to their
fullest potential is that the the way
that she and the feminists have done it
is to totally erase women and I think
this goes back way further than the
second wave you sometimes hear
conservatives the squishy kind they say
we love the feminism but only the you
know the second wave not the third wave
or we like the first wave not the second
whatever we're on like the 10th wave now
but it's been a problem from the
beginning even Mary walstone craft who
who founds feminism with the Vindication
of the rights of woman she writes that
uh Providence has created men in such a
way that they are um more inclined to
Virtue and they're more endowed with
virtue and I think that's exactly what
glorious steum thinks because the the
way that second wave feminism actually
was practiced was it denied the virtues
particular to women and it said the only
way to be virtuous and to flourish is to
be a man so if women want to be virtuous
and flourish they got to dress like men
and they got to have the same attitudes
towards sex as men and they got to work
in the workplace exactly as men do and
they just have to pretend to be men but
I think that's very uh disrespectful to
women and harmful to them because if a
woman tries to be a man she's always
going to fail just look at the pen swim
team now
when and defeat them this is why some
feminists wisely are turning against
the I think women are great and women
have a wonderful nature and when women
are fully women they can really flourish
and when they pretend to be men they get
miserable I think um what a lot of
feminists would push back on or worry
about is this idea that we have a cribed
gender to certain things are kind of
agendered so for example when it comes
to the workplace um the idea that like
oh no women must stay at home going out
and working as a man's job seems to be
something that a lot of people have
contention with because it seems like
I'm not saying that women don't have a
place at home taking care of children
but it doesn't seem like it should
necessarily be limited to just that so
for example um even like throughout
history you still have women who despite
taking care of home also have like side
jobs or side hustles or stuff like that
to help contribute to the family so I
think this whole idea that's like oh no
like women are just trying to be men
sometimes I wonder oh no we are just
saying that this is for a man to do even
though it seems like there's more
opportunity for women to participate in
those Arenas as well I think you've just
made my point though which is that you
say throughout history including long
before feminism ever came onto the scene
women did plenty of things you know in
addition to just being barefoot and
pregnant in the kitchen right they had
uh they were involved in their Community
they had side hustles as you put it um
so so they did all these things I mean I
think of the most famous anti-feminist
American of the 20th century it was
philis Schley philis Schley had six kids
she was a housewife she uh said The only
person whose permission she needs for
her political activism is her husbands
which irritated feminists to no end
she's one of the most important
political figures of the whole Century
she single-handedly killed the Equal
Rights Amendment traveled all over the
country one of the most vaunted figures
in the American right uh she she was
able to do a lot of things in public but
she recognized that her particular role
that her husband never could have that
no man on Earth ever could have even if
he kids himself is to have children to
be a woman to be graceful
to to do the things that men can't do
and so she can do she can do things
beyond that as well but uh if if you
erase the particular advantages of women
the women are put at a disadvantage I
mean the problem is women were also
excluded from doing a lot of things so I
don't think anyone here thinks they're
no differences between men and women but
there's a lot of overlap as well and
while men and women may be different on
something on average to look at a woman
like I think you're you and some of your
other conservatives are Under Fire for
saying oh if it's a female pilot I'm
automatically going to assume that this
person is incompetent I've never said
that though if if an airline tells me
that they are prioritizing Dei over uh
Merit in the cockpit I would probably
book another airl okay and that's I
guess that's a I get what you're I get
that but my point is like to say women
are just more emtional than men that may
be true on average but to then look at a
woman and just be like automatically I'm
going to assume this woman is more
emotional I think that isn't that the so
why is it true on average though it may
be true on average because we're
different I've never said we're not
different but the problem is to say
we're different and then put us into
categories and be like there can be no
out overlap women have to do this role
and men have to do this role that's I
think what feminism is pushing back on
what you're arguing for is a kind of
feminism that says actually uh all the
differences between men and women that's
totally true in the aggregate you know
in these two different types but on rare
occasion there's going to be some that R
like let's say like okay gender roles
like let's say most people like let's
say 70 to 80% of people will fall into
natural gender roles but then there's
still 20% of our population that may not
and do we make a society where we force
that 20% into these roles or do we allow
choice I think a lot of feminism the
Cornerstone feminism is choice for women
you can't I'm not so sure about that I'm
not so sure because there was a famous
debate between Betty fedan Who was the
prominent American feminist and Simone
deovir one of the most famous feminists
of the 20th century it was in 1975 and
Betty freedan said what you said she
said look I think we should give women a
choice to maybe they want to go out into
the workplace or maybe they want to stay
home and raise their kids but they
should have a choice and Simon De boir
who was a more consistent and
intelligent feminist said there can't be
a choice and the reason there can't be a
choice is that if given the choice most
women would stay at home and if most
women stay at home women will not be
free if we want true women's Liberation
women must be forced to be free and
freedan recoiled from this because she
knew it wasn't going to play well in
Peoria but Simon deir had had the right
point and I think the more consistent
feminists have agreed with her I don't
know I mean feminism has like it's gone
so many different directions so to pick
the feminist that we don't agree with
for this debate I don't know if that's
conducive to also I'm not necessarily
sure when you're saying like oh no um
most women would stay at home that's a
choice that they would have because when
you look at like the uprisings of like
feminism or when when that gained the
most traction it was post-war era um
partly because of the reason why is
because during these War eras men went
out they were drafted they had to go
fight etc etc women were expected to
take up more um traditional male spaces
work and when the men came back yeah um
what ended up happening is that a lot of
women did not want to leave the jobs
that they had they wanted to keep um the
somewhat level of financial Independence
that they were able to gain and that's
why we see like these huge like feminist
uprisings during those periods of time
so it seems to me if you're saying that
most wom would St home um that just
wouldn't happen like women would have
not had like these feminist movements go
forward well the the feminists didn't
want to leave their jobs but women
broadly perhaps did so anecdotally
people write in a lot and they tell me
Michael you know i' at least while my
kids are little I'd love to stay home
and raise them maybe I'll go back to
work after but I just can't it's you
can't raise a family in America for the
average person today on one income and
that's a result of women entering the
workforce and wages decrease which is
why not only the radical left but also
the more um commercially minded
rightwing was in favor of that it's the
same reason they're in favor of mass
migration it just lowers wages for
people uh a lot of women however seem to
feel not that they have the choice to to
go to work but that they have to and
this is expressed in a famous study that
came out of upen and was published by
Yale in 2008 which was the Paradox of
declining female happiness and I love
the way the study opens up right in the
abstract it says despite the past 35
years I'm paraphrasing but despite the
past 35 years showing so much marked
progress and Improvement in the lives of
women women's happiness according to
this meta analysis has declined both
absolutely and relative to men so it's
not even just that everyone got more
miserable because of I don't know a bad
economy or something women in particular
became less happy despite all these
objective improvements to their lives so
to me the the obvious rejoinder to that
is well maybe those objective
improvements namely feminism that's the
thing that happened between 1973 and
2008 uh maybe that wasn't an objective
good maybe that was just to me the
obvious rejoiner of that is that women
are becoming disillusioned with the life
they had prior they're like leaving the
cave so to speak allegorically and also
I don't think you should use
self-reported happiness as a metric of
Justice or any like objective good
because you can plot self-reported
happiness with pretty much any variable
like highest reported crime violent
crime in the United States also is
directly correlated to self-reported
happiness does that mean one cause is
the other no does that mean we should
think what you mean highest vient crime
is I'm just saying in the periods of
time when we've had the most violent
crime in the United States there's also
a correlation between highest rates of
self-reported Happiness well not not
according to the survey I just cited
right if if happiness has been declining
steadily especially for women since 1973
to 2008 you had a major crime spike in
the early 90s but you didn't have a
major spike in happiness so perhaps
there's some survey that you're
referring to in some City somewhere it
wouldn't uh but also even women living
traditional lifestyles are seeing a
downfall in happiness so why is it the
women who are still living the type of
lifestyle that you would probably
prescrib to women or also having a
decrease in happiness I'm not I'm not
convinced of that the Institute of
family studies that a big and there's a
lot of data out there that actually
children make you less happy so there is
this problem happen happening where
we're like okay why are people less
happy but we don't know we don't know
what it is and then you would expect
then that the like if you looked at the
most unhappiest countries you would
expect Canada the Nordic count
Scandinavian countries because they're
very egalitarian and you're not seeing
that they they actually have higher
happiness levels well they have the
highest rates of alcoholism in the world
you think of Denmark Norway Iceland in
particular so I don't know how happy
they are now you're changing but if
we're going to just go by what makes
people happy I don't know if I I think
there are arguments to be made about
like and those things may make people
less happy but this idea that's because
women aren't having children when we
also have data a lot of data that shows
children especially in the United States
has the biggest happiness Gap and then
we're seeing that other countries that
are more feminist are also not having
like if you compare like Scandinavian
countries to like the East like I'm my
parents are immigrates from Iran Iran
has really high unhappiness levels a lot
of countries yeah exactly so I don't
know if you can say that this is causing
that right well yeah Nordic countries
also have much more homogeneity which is
correlated with
happiness but so they're all all um of
those differences but I I think the uh
the point about children making you
unhappy and the point about leaving the
cave I think those are both a little bit
of a cope because they're uh beled by
the fact that uh if it were just that
women were coming into their own now and
they were recognizing the oppression of
which they were not conscious previously
then why would they keep getting less
and less happy you know at a certain
point aren't you supposed to turn the
corner and become more happy in your
Independence but that's not what's
happened for 35 years it just gets worse
worse and worse including relative to
men and then for children you you look
over the past U what 70 plus years not
74 years since 1950 to present day the
marriage rate has dropped by 60% and the
birth rate has dropped by
50% so just looking at the whole society
we are having many many fewer children
than we were before and yet we're much
less happy even even like like Pakistan
are having less kids sure I'm just I'm
just pointing out you're saying that
having fewer children makes you happier
and I'm saying we're having many fewer
children and Americans are much less
happy and you you see this even Beyond
just random surveys I kind I kind of
want to push back on this idea that
we've gotten um more unhappy as time has
progressed because at least to my
understanding what's happened in the
last like you know 20 or 30 years is an
increased awareness of like mental
health and what that means so it's not
necessarily that people were really
happy before and now suddenly are
miserable it's just that now we're
actually having data where people can
talk openly about their mental health
unhappiness and not be as stigmatized as
before if we look at the 1950s and even
like Housewives around that time we see
like there is actually like a huge rate
of like narcotic usage and basically
like prescriptions to that level um so
I'm not necessarily if I would go as far
to say um yeah we've gotten unhappiness
as time we've gotten more unhappy as
time has gone by I would say more likely
oh no we've been able to properly report
measure and assess mental health as time
has gone by what listen I'm uh very
inclined towards your view that social
scientific studies are bunk I mean
there's a major replication prices I
think it's all ridiculous I will cite
those social science stats when they
serve my argument because why not that's
what we do these days but I agree I'm
I'm skeptical of measuring happiness and
all the rest of it but on the mental
health point I think here we do have
some pretty firm data and it contradicts
the argument you're making which is uh
right now one in five middle-aged women
in the country is hooked on
anti-depression drugs on any given day
they're taking them women are two and a
half times as likely as men to take
these depression drugs it is ubiquitous
at this point
and and the rates of taking depression
drugs are going up it's getting much
worse so if we're not getting uh less
and less happy why do people keep taking
more and more depression drugs why were
housewives in the 50s Downing like a
bottle of wine at lunch every day I'm
just saying I I'm not so sure I mean
these are anec weting self-medication
now with actually like medically backed
drugs that actually help women with
their mental health issues it's also now
that when you're sad you just go to the
doctor and they give you anti-depressant
drugs I don't know how much more
depressed people actually are other than
the fact that they're just dishing them
out to everybody and they're dishing
them out more and more and more sure you
can blame the pharmaceutical industry
the medical industry I'm just pointing
out you know one what in order to argue
against these social science statistics
one has to just turn toward
unfalsifiable anecdotes and memes you
know all the housewives were all
miserable in the 50s they were secretly
you know drinking behind their husband's
backs but I maybe they were maybe they
weren't all I have are the data
available saying that more people are on
anti-depressants it's not telling you
why it's not telling you what caused it
it's not telling you
well that's what we're debating here is
what could have caused it you're saying
oh it's no but I'm I'm not saying you
know maybe they hate their husband maybe
they hate their kids maybe they don't
like you know the weather in their town
I think ADHD is a great example of this
anyone now can just be like oh I have
trouble focusing does everyone have ADHD
or are people just getting these drug
like you know these are questions that
we should ask before we jump to a
conclusion that no I agree look I think
that they're pathologizing a lot of
ordinary aspects of human nature but I
think part of the reason that we do that
is because we're so radically
misinterpreting human nature which
brings us right back to feminism